[Music]
[Applause]
welcome
to the bonus show reports are today's
episode
will be award-winning and that is a very
exciting thing i know for many people in
the audience
let's start in wisconsin republicans who
control the wisconsin legislature
this week convened and within seconds
ended a special section
a session called by the democratic
governor tony evers
to expand medicaid and that was the
opportunity for the state to get a
billion dollar bonus in federal
coronavirus relief funding
this was money made available by the
federal government states can say hey
let's expand medicaid if you do it you
get a billion dollar bonus in coveted
funding
and they said no the senate and assembly
gaveled in and adjourned the special
session in an almost empty chamber with
only a handful of lawmakers there
it lasted 40 seconds in the house or i
guess they call it the assembly there
the senate was done in 10 seconds no
debate no votes taken
um and the uh
this is yet another defeat for democrats
on this issue and
you know democrats for years have been
saying let's expand eligibility
for the medicaid program it's called
badger care plus
in wisconsin i kind of like that this
time it was not only let's do it it was
like let's do it and get the billion
dollars that's on the table
and democrats said it made no sense not
to do it
but republicans just don't want it what
what do we even say at this point
i don't know because this wouldn't
affect the tax rates in wisconsin it
wouldn't affect the budget in wisconsin
this money's coming from the federal
government right so
it's just free for them to take and they
pass up on it maybe it has to do with
that strict
father morality thing that we always
talk about well they
claim republicans are claiming that even
though it doesn't cost anything
now the money for this could dry up so
they vote to do it
and then it's covered from this billion
initially but then the billion goes away
and then they've got to figure out how
to pay for it and either raise taxes or
go into debt that's the claim from
republicans okay but then you just
address the issue when it comes up again
right and maybe you
change around the eligibility
requirements when it comes up again but
you would hope that for now at least in
the meantime you would do what's best
for your constituents especially because
uh you only qualify for medicaid in
wisconsin if you're making under twelve
thousand eight hundred and eighty
dollars a year
yeah um and this would allow them to up
that eligibility for people making
under seventeen thousand seven hundred
and seventy four dollars a year which i
mean it's not like you're
all that well off if you're making under
18 000 a year you should be able to
qualify for medicaid
that's the crazy thing that they're a
bit they're basically saying
if you make 15 000 a year you shouldn't
qualify or i mean
or at least let me i want to be more
charitable
maybe some of the republicans think if
you make fifteen thousand dollars you
should qualify but that this is not
not the way to fund it and to do it
right and then you're uh you're gonna
have to resort to finding a private plan
you're probably not going to be able to
afford the best private plan out there
maybe your premiums would be low but
your co-pay is going to be through the
roof your deductible is going to be
really high as well and so it's just
going to be
poor health insurance right you know
that just goes into the problem that we
have with this country of so many people
being underinsured
and people still going bankrupt even if
they have coverage because the coverage
just doesn't cover enough
and yeah i mean there's really not that
much downside for republicans doing this
i think it's virtue signaling myself i
mean i know they make the point about
how they have to
take a long-term approach the budget in
case the federal government's money
dries up with this fund
well one other aspect to that that's
important
the federal government reimburses
more to states for care
when you do the medicaid expansion
if you account for that not only do they
get the billion dollars for doing the
expansion
but the calculation from the fiscal
bureau
is that between uh 2013 and 2019
they would have saved almost 3 billion
because they would have been getting
reimbursed more money by the federal
government for having done the expansion
so
once you account for that it's like a
crazy no-brainer that they should be
doing this and do you think this is the
type of issue
that uh lawmakers in wisconsin
republican ones especially will have to
go back to their constituents and
discuss or i don't know the average
citizen there doesn't even pay attention
to issues like this
i mean certainly if they had such a
quick legislative session uh that would
suggest that maybe it didn't make all
that much news but you know it's really
how this
my instinct is they've calculated
there's not going to be
consequences to just dismissing this out
of hand that's
uh that's that's my sense but we'll
continue to follow it
uh the republican governors association
threw out
my pillows mike lindell after he showed
up to their spring conference in
tennessee lindell said he flew to
nashville monday to go to this three-day
meeting
but that only a few minutes after he got
his credential at the marriott hotel
an event coordinator in the lobby said
he's not allowed at any of the events
the republican governors association
official who spoke on the condition of
anonymity
said that lindell tried to join
transportation for members only
for a dinner at the tennessee governor's
mansion and was denied
and that those events are for rga
members and mike lindell is not
currently an rga
member so there's kind of two sides of
this one is that this is being seen as a
big snub by the republican governors
association
the other is like hey listen he tried to
go to the governor's mansion like he
clearly
not every attendee can go to that and he
just tried to go somewhere he's not
supposed to go
i don't really know the truth but it
seems to me that there are many
republican governors
that aren't wacky trumpists and think
that this guy is toxic and should be
nowhere near their political party
yeah like mike lindell mentioned i think
during a newsmax
segment that he's not invited on fox
news anymore yeah so i feel like the
mainstream republicans are
done with him and many of these
republican governors around the country
aren't the craziest like i feel like
there are a lot of
crazy radical members of the house for
example but there are more reasonable
republican
governors out there and so it would make
sense that they wouldn't want him at
this event
i mean he is sort of a celebrity figure
so if they did like him then i think
that they would open their doors to him
i think it's
the first explanation about how the
republican governors just didn't want
him there
um and yeah i really wonder what's going
on with mike lindell like
for you know the first few months that
he was famous after he uh crashed the
rose garden conference and right donald
trump i thought he was just grifting i
thought he was just trying to sell
a bunch of pillows uh and you know
really appeal to that right-wing
audience but as this stuff continues to
play out as he's flying across the
country to hide voting machines and
whatever the hell else he's doing
it seems to me like maybe he really has
something going on
right yeah something's going on all
right that's for sure and you know i was
actually thinking you because you
mentioned the rose garden thing
when we watch uh joe biden and kamala
harris
do you know a completely boring and
normal event where they announced that
we got 200 million vaccination doses
done
and you know whatever and then they
invite someone up to speak and it's just
like it's all so
boring and normal and then we think back
to a year ago
where trump says we're making a big
announcement in the rose garden
and up comes mike lindell and says we're
turning my pillow factories into mask
factories and donald trump is a gift for
is a literal gift from god
how insane was that you know i i'm
reminded of george w bush's comment to
hillary clinton after trump's
inauguration where he said
well that was some weird [ __ ] yeah no it
was it was a totally insane four years
the trump presidency
it was entertaining yeah i mean
something entertaining in a way that
like a train wreck is
you have to watch because it's like it's
going on in front of you but you think
this is a disaster
especially for the country at large and
yeah like i think a lot of people were
watching that rose garden event because
that was one of the first public
addresses that trump gave on the topic
of coronavirus like he gave that
address from the oval office and then i
think that rose garden press conference
came a few days later
was it that much that's interesting i
thought it might have been a few weeks
later but that's interesting
maybe it feels like it was definitely in
that early space yeah
yeah maybe you were right maybe it was
early april or something like that and
it took a long time for them to start
socially distancing and of course they
weren't wearing the masks and all that
stuff
yeah but yeah that was a crazy moment
and um yeah i mean it goes to that point
that you made yesterday on the show
how back in 2016 the access hollywood
tape came out and we all thought it was
this
big scandal it was front page news
everywhere and then he fast forward a
few years now we have a former president
who is being investigated criminally
they're forming a grand jury
and that wasn't even the top story of
the day it's insane i'm desensitized to
it
hey one one other thing on this um i
guess this is sort of related
so amazon has signed an agreement
to buy the film studio metro goldwyn
mayer mgm
and there are a whole bunch of people
including stephen colbert and others i
read a bunch of pieces about this
which are suggesting that here's the
real
idea behind bezos buying mgm
apparently the connection is i'm trying
to see if i if i understand this
correctly
by buying mgm bezos it's claimed
would get the rights to the old footage
of the apprentice
because of the companies the the company
who produced it
and owns the footage is uh is the same
um and thus the hypothesis
is there's all this crazy racist footage
of trump from behind the scenes at the
apprentice
bezos gets the footage and owns it
and then either can release it to
humiliate trump although it's like
at this point would racist footage of
trump really surprise anyone or change
anything i don't know
or bezos could use it to blackmail trump
in some way
or to get trump to stop attacking jeff
bezos publicly so much
what do you think about this uh i would
love to
see those comments come out from years
ago on the apprentice
and any way that we can go about doing
that would be terrific because i want to
hear what's on those tapes
um i don't think that was like the
primary reason why amazon decided to
purchase mgm i assume not it could have
just
been something that they realized later
on there's also the aspect about how
jeff bezos and trump don't like each
other very much like trump would always
attack
the washington post as the jeff bezos
owned the washington post
and so maybe this is jeff bezos trying
to get back at him after all these years
with an 8.45 billion dollar price tag
attached to it but you know they can
afford it for sure
yeah um i don't know it's it's
interesting to think about like i
was hoping that those tapes would come
out at some point they never did um
you're right about how maybe they
wouldn't make that much of an effect on
things at this
point especially because i think even
the most die-hard trump supporters
would just write off the tapes as
fabricated
and trump or irrelevant or a hit job or
whatever
yeah i mean if you haven't left trump if
you haven't left team trump by this
point i don't think you're going to ever
no and then the other thing is it's a
question as to whether this really even
gives amazon access to those tapes it's
there's there's a hypothesis that it
does
uh but it's not obvious to me that
that's actually the case and and it's
not been stated yet so
a lot of question marks remain about
this and and i don't think jeff bezos
jeff bezos may be a lot of things i
don't think that
he cares that much about getting those
tapes to embarrass trump anyway
you think i mean i just feel like he's
the richest person on the planet right
yeah um i mean he can certainly buy
whatever he wants he's
lived a life of luxury for so long it
gets to a point where like
i feel like maybe for him to be
entertained
this is what he needs to do for fun
because he's so rich essentially
yeah he has to embarrass a former
president that's how he's going to go
about
maybe i mean that doesn't surprise me
yeah no instead of building another
yacht he's like maybe i'll try to
embarrass her
that's that's totally plausible uh okay
so let me give people an update
about what's going on with the show we
are off on monday for monday memorial
day
no show monday uh that's it so just no
show on monday
then we'll be back for a couple weeks we
are then going to be doing
summer break number one of four
no summer break the we are doing a
summer break i don't know the full
scope of the rest of the summer quite
yet um it's going to be the last week in
june so we'll be here
all of june for you starting june 1st
right after the monday holiday we'll be
here all of june
but then on the 28th of june we will be
off
and it goes directly into the fourth of
july holiday so we'll be off the week of
the 28th
this year because it's a sunday 4th of
july we'll also be off
monday the 5th of july that will be the
day that we are observing the 4th of
july
if that makes sense that's the plan for
june i don't know is there more to say
that's just the plan i guess
yeah we'll just have to keep reminding
people every single day on the bonus
show until the vacation arrives and then
maybe even during the vacation we can
post daily updates to remind people that
we're not going to be
producing a show that day now i do have
an admission to make about
that vacation um i made a very
big statement in late march during
spring break
about how although i was traveling for
the first time
since the start of the pandemic i was
not going to the covet hellscape
that was the state of florida
um i will be making a
principled and triumphant return to the
state of
florida during summer break
in june yes you're a brave man for going
to florida in the summer time
yeah we're we're in florida are you
willing to say that or are we leaving
that off the table it's going to be down
in that southern tip
that hispanic people love so much and
that's why i just love it i i love you
know it's going to be the miami area
it's going to be i'm not going to give
exact dates i won't tell you where i'll
be staying or anything about that
but uh no i'm go i i really do love it
there i know it's really hot and humid
but i just go to the beach
and go to restaurants i like i am
following the cdc guidance on
what is safe to do as a vaccinated
person and so yeah i am making my return
to florida
maybe famous last words let's hope not
no that sounds like a great time i'm
sure you'll be fine
fully vaccinated of course and uh yeah
we're going to start to see more of a
discrepancy when it comes to kobe cases
and blue states versus red states yeah
you have your personal protection
i'm sure they'll still require masks on
the plane at least sure
um so you'll be okay you'll be ready and
i'll have to make my summer vacation
plans
soon too and then i can tell everyone in
the audience what my plans are going to
be yeah you can announce where in
florida you'll be going so that'll be an
exciting day
um no i'm kidding so uh yeah it's by the
way speaking of which
states they you can they they're they're
now
interesting data presentations about
highly vaccinated versus lowly
vaccinated states
the most vaccinated states have seen a
40
case reduction over the last i don't
know exactly how many weeks so
vaccinated states 40 down on cases
unvaccinated states four percent
up on cases so this really is making a
difference at this point in time
yeah it's not even like we have to ask
ourselves why yeah like why why are we
seeing some states do better
and why are we seeing some states do
worse like i mean over the past year
plus
that was a big question especially like
during the summer of 2020 when we
started to see like florida get worse
and
places like massachusetts were doing
better we had to sort of hypothesize
now that the science is in the data's in
and we know that these vaccines are
highly effective and so yeah it does
make sense that you would see a
correlation like that
all right correlation and causation not
always the same thing
in this case appear to be exactly the
same thing very important uh takeaway
all right we'll be back tomorrow new
show new bonus show see everybody then